today the minister's secrete a general
general approach on the single digital
gateway it is another step towards
completing the digital single market
single digital gateway will make it
easier for our people and companies to
find the information that they seek and
use the services they need
wherever in the youth they live work or
do business
and also assess the importance of
finalizing negotiations with the
European Parliament on unjustified job
blocking and removing the barriers of
e-commerce
core apprenticed the agreement yesterday
and hopefully by Christmas next year you
citizens will have already be able to
enjoy a broader choice of goods and
services when shopping online we had a
very productive I think discussion very
interesting on the EU industrial
strategy but we all agree that
industrial strategy is a common
responsibility of all of us into Europe
in Europe the Commission the Member
States regional authorities all we have
to contribute to it so we welcome the
again the positive reaction to our
communication on industrial strategy and
the Presidency's report we will now
carry on with developing and
implementing strategy and the next
points of our lunchtime discussion was
focused on the future of the car
industry we focus on the on the future
because we need to start to look as a
Member States also and as a commission
at the big challenges ahead of the
automotive industry and ahead of the
mobility in Europe in general
to move to the move to electric mobility
and generally non emission mobility